[Music]
invision in the Scarlet Witch vol 2
number 3 scarlet and division found out
it was impossible for human and an
Android to conceive so Scarlet Witch had
her very own Marvel Immaculate
Conception she's magic to make herself
pregnant and gave birth to twin boys
myself the vision had his memory wiped
he and scarlet got a divorce and the
twins turned out to be shards of the
demon Mephisto the Avengers and x-men
decided she was too dangerous to live
and in an act of self-preservation in
house of M Scarlet Witch created a new
reality where mutants were the majority
and magneto was the ruler but this too
backfired and Scarlet Witch was forced
to take action
whispering the words what's next for
scarlet
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Doctor Strange -
Scarlet Witch video all about how
they're setting up x-men creating the
space for that in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
there were a couple really big things
including Patrick Stewart talking about
MCU x-men stuff so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to my channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos I also have that extra infinity
Saga box set giveaway for all the
blu-ray set all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave your
biggest theory about how they'll
introduce x-men in the MCU so you've all
probably seen that video that I attached
at the beginning of this of elizabeth
olsen introducing the concept of all the
stories that they're going to cover with
the wan division series and with Doctor
Strange - mostly setting up the space
for how mutants can exist in the MCU if
we've never seen them before where have
they been this whole time
so that's a really big deal but then
there's also the revelation that Kevin
Feige wants Patrick Stewart to come back
as Professor X in new Marvel movies
which we never really thought about
before everyone always wondered what
they're gonna do with those Fox
characters now that they have access to
them Patrick Stewart was recently
promoting his new Star Trek Picard TV
show that's being released this week and
people were asking him about the Fox
Disney deal and if we'd ever see him
again after the Logan Wolverine movie
and he dropped a few big info bombs
about what's been happening behind the
scenes so we'll just break all this down
top-10 style starting with the Scarlet
Witch x-men stuff all the big stories
that they're covering with Avengers 1
division episodes a little bit with
Doctor Strange - but Doctor Strange - is
a much bigger movie setting up even
bigger wider MCU changes all the Scarlet
Witch Wan divisions stuff is really the
beginning of that the tip of the spear
so that first story she talks about
Scarlet Witch and visions relationship
we've all seen in the Marvel movies so
far they covered it in the comic book
miniseries from the mid 80s but there
are two volumes to that volume one was
at the beginning of the 80s and it
introduced the idea that Scarlet Witch
and quicksilver's father was really
magneto up to that point in the comics
their parents were different you've all
probably seen the Michael Fassbender
magneto edits showing him as scarlet
witch's father in the MCU how would that
even make sense if they're from sokovia
and there were some deleted scenes that
showed flashbacks from Avengers age of
Ultron where their parents and her
father definitely did not look like
fassbender Marvel Comics also retcon
that a couple years ago - saying that
magneto wasn't really her father none of
that really matters now anymore because
they got the Fox characters back and
they just gave control of Marvel Comics
to Kevin Feige in addition to all the TV
show stuff and all the movie stuff he's
always had control the movies now he
controls pretty much everything that
they do
number nine Scarlet Witch and visions
relationship from the volume 2 comic is
more relevant to the wand division
series because not only do we know that
she's gonna try and live her best fake
life
remember fake life with a version of
vision the comic book miniseries is also
where they introduced their twin
children Wiccan in speed for the first
time I did a video a little while ago
about the casting news and the videos
that were released it does seem like the
children are gonna show up on the one
division series some form of her
children because during the series
they're introducing the idea of her
chaos magic in reality warping number
eight elizabeth Olsen also narrates the
story about how Marvel came back after
that comic and retcon her children say
that they were really the soul shards of
Mephisto mostly because the Marvel
editor at the time hated that the
writers of the miniseries gave Scarlet
Witch children back in the 80s Marvel
was like no kids we hate that idea so
the whole soul shard story was just
because they hated what the previous
writers had done we'll see some fun
Easter eggs for that story during the
one division series and Doctor Strange -
it won't be a literal copy-paste
situation with the story but there will
be some fun Easter eggs for that so
number 7 then she narrates how vision
got destroyed in the comics then was
rebuilt and brought back as the white
vision they're also kind of doing a
version of that with the Wanda vision
episodes everyone asked why vision was
repaired when Hulk snapped everyone back
during Avengers endgame it would have
been a very easy thing for the Hulk to
do to think to repair him when he was
bringing everyone else back why leave
him in pieces it doesn't make sense the
real reason is because they were leaving
that for the Wanda vision series to take
care of Scarlet Witch bringing a version
of vision back using her reality warping
powers in chaos magic but talking about
Easter eggs just like the white vision
something won't quite be right with him
so in the comics when white vision is
brought back he doesn't have the special
mental framework or consciousness
transplant that he had before so he
comes back with no emotions he's this
cold unfeeling
robot but just like the other stories
that they're adapting for the blonde
division serious it'll just be based on
that it won't be the exact same thing
like he might not be full-blown white
vision number six obviously the things
that we're all really thinking about is
when she talks about the House of M
story that they're doing that part of
the one division series they're covering
is really the reality warping power part
so when she starts using her chaos magic
and really warping reality it probably
won't be as complete in terms of
covering the entire earth as it was in
the comics but same basic concept the
multiverse is the next big thing in the
MCU we got a taste for that during
avengers endgame with the alternate
timelines but one division is literally
creating alternate realities using her
abilities as they continue to evolve
like they said back in the Comic Con
panel turning her into the comic book
version of The Scarlet Witch that Kevin
Feige said you will find out why she is
called The Scarlet Witch so think of the
TV show version as being a reverse no
more mutant situation creating the
quote-unquote possibility of mutants in
the MCU and because it seems like they
might let versions of her children
survive into future Young Avengers
projects and other Marvel movies and TV
shows that also seems like it's gonna be
part of the reverse no more mutants
think like if she were to whisper
mutants all the time all over the place
don't you kind of wish they were ready
to release a Super Bowl trailer for one
division in the next couple of weeks
they're still filming the series right
now so they're not ready to release any
footage it's probably gonna be awhile
before we actually see that number five
WTF there was a clip of that elizabeth
Olsen video at the beginning of this
that I cut out that involves a big
Doctor Strange crossover because the
version of that they're doing on the TV
shows and in Doctor Strange 2 is gonna
be very different the whole reason why
she's crossing over with Doctor Strange
2 is mostly because of the main villain
of that movie being from the multiverse
just like Dormammu is from another
dimension I think we all believe the new
villain is going to be nightmare there
are some people that are holding out
hope for Mephisto just because he's so
tied to scarlet witch's children and her
back story in the comics but the new
main villain threatening our reality
having something to do with how Scarlet
Witch warps reality allowing the villain
to enter earth so that's sort of the
point of crossover with Doctor Strange
protecting our Earth from other
realities there was a brand new plot
synopsis for Doctor Strange to that
posted recently but I'm not totally sure
if it's real or fake
waiting a little while before I do video
about that number four WTF getting to
the bigger Patrick Stewart x-men stuff
so Patrick Stewart recently revealed
that Kevin Feige was trying to get him
to come back as Professor X in new
Marvel movies to a big bombshell he
didn't say which movies those were going
to be and he didn't say when they were
trying to get him to come back just that
Marvel Studios wanted him to come back
and even if he never does come back
which I don't think he's going to
anytime soon based on what he said it
says a lot about what Kevin Feige is
trying to do when he starts crossing
over the big mainstream x-men characters
into the MCU so number three that also
means they probably spoken with Hugh
Jackman to see if he'd ever want to come
back in more Marvel MCU movies before
Logan was released a long time ago Hugh
Jackman did say that if he ever had a
chance to be in a Marvel movie with the
Avengers he would totally come back but
that was before Logan after Logan was
released because that movie went down so
well it was received so well by the fans
he and Patrick Stewart kind of said that
they were so happy with the closure that
that movie gave them it was so good they
didn't need to come back they wanted to
end their time on a high note the same
cannot be said for all the other x-men
characters that were unfortunate enough
to be in x-men Dark Phoenix like James
McAvoy and Michael Fassbender so number
two I do think that James McAvoy and
Michael Fassbender have been approached
by Marvel about coming back at some
point neither one has publicly said
anything about it James McAvoy has made
some jokes about showing up as other MCU
characters like if you could be in a
Marvel movie who would you want to play
and he just started listing a bunch of
characters and even if none of those
Foxx x-men actors return right away
there's always the chance for a Spider
Man into the spider-verse cameo
situation with an Avengers multiverse
crossover movie Secret Wars is the story
that we all go back to the one that's
just so crazy that it would make sense
that a bunch of different versions of
characters would show up so that's where
you would slot in a bunch of cameos if
you're gonna do them but number one
none of this includes Marvel's plans for
Ryan Reynolds Deadpool character in the
Deadpool 3 movie which Marvel is already
in the process of developing I posted a
video a few weeks ago of Ryan Reynolds
explaining what's going on with Deadpool
3 so I'll link that at the end of this
but suffice to say they're working on it
it's being developed as a rated
our movie but because of that it'll only
be loosely related to the MCU he is a
Marvel character Kevin Feige in Bob Iger
the CEO of Disney have both referred to
him as being an MCU character but the
MCU movies are pg-13 so any rated-r
stuff or movies that Deadpool makes will
only be loosely connected to the MCU
there was a new Iron Man video that I
was working on I'll try to post that in
the next few days Marvel also just
released their first look teaser of the
brand new dark version of Captain
America so I'll do a breakdown of that
that should post later tonight
congratulations to our kin productions
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details
everyone click here for that new
Deadpool 3 Ryan Reynolds video and click
here for my new sinister 6 Morbius
trailer video and Easter eggs thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome see you guys tonight
[Music]